we have one of my favorite guests on the
show in his first year with the Kansas
City Chiefs seventh season in the
National Football League he is Tyrann
Mathieu how are you tiring I'm better
for talking to you what's it been like
so far in Kansas City for your tyrannous
opposed to your other stops in the NFL
yeah it's been a fairly smooth
transition so we got a lot of young guys
in a locker room a lot of energy lot of
juice I got a plethora of guys that
could you know make plays all over Phil
so it's been it's been fun to say the
least
I mean are you considered in OG in the
league now turn well I am but definitely
in this in this in this locker room so I
wanted to owe these guys on a Detroiter
and that's a first for me um so uh I
feel like I've had great practice you
know I've studied under guys like I just
Peterson and you know I spent some time
with JD white so uh I feel like I'm I
feel like I'm me quick quick to kind of
lead the guys yeah Tyron if I told you
at the combine that you'd be taken by a
team and not just for your playing
ability but for your leadership
abilities and to be looked at as a
beacon in the locker room what would you
told me surprised you know given you
know the circumstances you know seven
eight years ago definitely didn't see
myself here rich um but you know a so
grateful man I've always you know been
truly blessed to have but people around
me and even when I came into the league
in Arizona and Bruce Arians and that
structure I thank all those little
things that people have really showed me
and helped me with us really got me to
this point so I'm really grateful rich
and then what about this offense from
your perspective Tyron you've seen a lot
in this league in seven years but
there's that Unicorn at cornerback and
then the rest of the offense what has it
been like for you to practice against it
well it's been rather tough to say the
least
rich I mean if they got guys all over
the sill Dom I mean you know between
Tyreke Hill and you know obviously
Travis Kelce and Sammy Watkins on even a
young boy nikola Hardman so they got a
plethora of talent on that side guys
they can really run
the field and you know make plays and it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't it's not a
bad thing you have a great quarterback
you know like patch mulch and based on
what you've seen who's the fastest on
your team who's the fastest
oh sorry kill I've never seen anything
like it and he's not just fast which the
guy can run around he's very crafty to
catch every ball could run every route
so we'll be really excited that wants me
once we get him back well in terms of
getting him back I know you haven't
gotten on the practice field yet but
what has he looked like over the last
couple of weeks do you think he's got it
all together for Sunday perhaps well we
hope so
[Music]
you kind of look at the coaches and the
trainer's kind of you know half of that
but um like I said the guy he's always
in shape he's always ready to go he
always a always has a smile on their
faces we also uh you know like I said
it'll be fun once we'll be able to
really get him back I know he's missed
you know catching those deep bass or
Patrick well give me give me something
from my home's you've seen in practice
where you're like okay III know what
everybody's been talking about give me
something that you've seen with your
honor yeah I can take you way back to
OTAs and you know um you know from him
throwing guys open to the no-look passes
to him throwing 70 yard bombs I mean a
guy the guy does it every single day he
practice it he's all to come he's all to
the competitive and I think the one
thing that I've learned because I've
been in league seven years I've been
around guys that that done it every
single day I think he's one of those
guys that puts in the work every single
day he's always one of the first guys in
a building and being a leader those are
the things that I that I really look at
when I'm thinking up other leaders and
uh he really possesses a lot of a lot of
great characteristics and then there's
the the sixth sense that he seems to
have and this past week Tyron I mean I
saw it obviously through the television
broadcast I don't know if it's come up
in any film sessions yet the moment
where before he took off on a 20
some-odd yard long
scramble he checked it appeared with the
official the the head ref to see if the
flag had been thrown for a holding that
he thought might be there looked at the
ref and then once saw there was no flag
knew it was meaningful enough to start
running I is that what happened tiring I
still don't know what happened but I'm
just being around the guy for the last
several months his awareness and student
rules he seems to know what everybody on
the field is doing where everybody on
the field is that even the referees and
in some in some cases he has great
awareness tremendous ability he's a heck
of a leader I'm really happy to be on
his team this tiring Matthew chief
safety here on the Rich Eisen show ok
Taryn let us hit the Wayback Machine a
little bit to your time at LSU and
through that the prism of the news here
out of the state of California that the
governor here is signed into law the
ability for student-athletes in the
state of California to hire an agent to
make money off of their name likeness
and image for endorsement purposes I'm
wondering how much money the honey
badger could have made back in the day
maybe maybe a million dollars so I'm not
sure rich I was I was pretty good back
in college but on I don't think that I
don't think that that rule is a bad rule
obviously are you know a lot of college
kids you know struggle with you know
obviously things other than tuition
because those things are handled by the
university but I think to give these at
least opportunity to kind of make some
money not all those guys will be able to
go on to the next level and provide for
their family so I think the more money
they can make in college while working
towards their goals I don't really see
that as a bad thing well I mean I had
Chris Webber in studio and our number
one and he told a story about how he was
hungry didn't have money for food for
lunch and he walked he was walking with
Mitch Albom the columnist and he said
I'm glad I have a a witness here they
looked in the window and there were two
people holding up his fat 5 Jersey at
the time and I'm wondering if did you
did you think at any moment in time like
hey you know
the amount of cash that was being made
or publicity being made off of you and
your play and your nickname honey badger
did you think that at the time any I
didn't I didn't put I didn't I didn't
put too much emphasis on it rich until
people that I knew started to make honey
badger t-shirts and then they started to
make money off of my name while I was in
school so I think at that moment I
realized that a lot of people are making
money you know off of my name off of my
likeness and unfortunately you know I'm
not saying any of that well what would
you say to people to think that the fact
that you if you would get cash off of
that from back in the day that that
would be destroying the fabric of
collegiate amateur athletics Tyron yeah
yeah I haven't I haven't thought about
that too much rich arm you know like I
said everybody's gonna have you know
different opinions about it I can just
say you know being a college athlete I
understand how hard it can be at times
especially if you're aren't one of the
better guys on the team so a lot of
those guys are really tight you know
when it comes to money and I feel like
if those guys are able to create a brand
for themselves and to you know really
get people to buy into their likeness
that you know yeah they should be able
to make you know someone else you know
what it'd be just a memorabilia or
anything like that and one of the things
I love talking about you Tyron is you
always keep it real you are always you
know open to answer any questions so let
me ask you this and then we'll move on
if money was injected into your
situation when you were in school would
that have made it better or worse do you
think given my situation rich everything
that I had been through from the
different challenges that I had outside
of football I think it'll probably be my
situation a bit worse rich to be
absolutely honest with you you know all
kind of people come into your life and
you don't know whether they're good or
bad you find those things out after the
fact so long but I think everybody you
know situations may vary but I know me
personally if I was making money in
college rich probably would have been a
good good deal for me turn math
you hear on the Rich Eisen show a couple
things off the field you're always doing
something in whatever community you're
in and also in your hometown what what
update can you give me on what you're up
to
charity wise community wise tire Matthew
oh yeah well I just had my backpack
giveaway last month so we blessed about
30 kids in the inner city in Kansas City
where the shop is pretty well I took
them to Dick's Sporting Goods so they I
got them all kind of winter clothes and
paying with a co-worker school and I'm
so out of my celebrity waiters dinner
coming up where my teammates are come in
kind of help serve dinner and so it took
a few folks and impulse to really raise
money for my charity so that I can
really begin the impact you know the
Kansas City community in the right way
so those are just a couple of things
that I've done four things that I have
coming up and for anybody who wants to
be part of it check it all out on your
Twitter or Instagram at Matthew
underscore arrow and in that regard I
want to close with this tyrant you know
I'm gonna bring this up with you because
I direct message it to you a tweet that
you put out about six days ago if we can
put it up on the screen so I can read it
off to everyone at home you tweeted when
entering a public bathroom you can tell
who eats what happened to tweet that
earlier this morning and I'm just like
man I can I can you know you walk in the
bathroom and you can literally smell
what everybody ate for dinner last night
in my mind rich nobody should smell that
bad early the heart right but um I guess
I guess we all have different diets so
was that your teammates you referring to
is that what you're saying is that a
teammate situation my guys I won't call
them all by name but yeah this got a
drink more green juices in the morning
you know drink more water you know open
that body up a little bit I don't know
if you're in the right town for that
time I mean
the barbecue in that town I mean you
take your pick that's all great and
obviously it's an issue but you've been
able to win despite it Tyron correct
right you're really good at what you do
Tarun clearly in all senses great chat
with you as always I really appreciate
you got it right let's stay in touch
let's stay in touch good luck on Sunday
night against the coho you got it
that's a Tyrann Mathieu everybody here
on the rich on section four more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app